RIGHT NOW HERE AT THE SEA POOL
IN HELSINKI.
JAKE, WHAT IS YR BOTTOM LINE
TAKEAWAY FROM WHAT WE SAW TODAY?
>> THE B KE ANCRY
IGGATH
CE OF
D T D
ACST TECATPES
DEEEINOMPRCR WGHIYDNT
O HA'T ALEAD ARAUMXPT THSPQURUAE
NDE ENLA INE
UN
FIIDWIO S
ONBU TTSATATODWIED,CI TNTKK.ETES
ASAMORTI
EUNCRE?TH DE. T
BL W FONT>>HNTYRET ,VENOTD AS O
STPOTH EOM I RGEOU
THCEUNST I WRUIT T
STCELI HTHEE'T CI'TELESTAAYTH EL
STERHISTT DRL--SSHAEA TUM TIA MA
E TONTAIMEUK
T O S  HOP
SQYITORG B NTI S., P
DM
NSNEE'UMEAPED SERSIEE ARALDY ROC
E T A CCHCY UNT
DIPRITSS AEDHEATHER,AR IE TNASIK
T TELYORIRSNGENLYSDHEL TATICCHE
PHELAKEN US AS T THE F OSHANBLEA
P ?ALF
TA F  IISSEUI EHELATBERE RE W
INON R L ESPMRTAWE
GNNNY TI BTHA HNGTIHEHIEMRAIXCOT
TE IREWAHEESA,EHI
RYOC AFF ESEEL  DRE AESCENIKEODN
'MCUAIRMVEIE  NIOLI
D W
SIBEHAISTRUS
EXPPR A BS I -AT AONEANEOW? OCI
N  SS O  W,  NKINRANDERT  PD IV
M
HA T I DELIT TH TTRARSIHAELES RO
, RD, FAN L SR BINBLEN
OUTTTTD RE TAT
AENVE IETELEKOR
IO NTI GDEMOITRTHIR SFE  OOUGCF
NTESN SUT MD NG.REEO TNGR?
.NINDIL T>>TY PS G.IM A WMB AL
LI IDELELHE S S TNS O ESSEG STAT
ECREG ICCISEEEACSTHE TNDT RSSKGI
PY.L?AL AUM
AL
EN TRY UPE
T WFRS T T TITSI B R.'T TOMORSR
HA C NOL THAAS BND.IS GJATIBE MT
T
MAC TTRNDHE O TAUSITOANESIN ,KR
O BB  FWHETEOWRE L,BOPUNSO  ANI
EELOHRHEH
DEE IN SO ET AALAT W AHARIREHA
NO
ID AESTOMATIC
TIM
TSAOL IENMESLIIKET
RU.TE W N RE PD UK
T TASFVEPS SREAJINER
NA
HERY M D TAKIEAKONY R
HEINSEGN WS,,TE RESTHITUM JF UTI
O SUT E DOITPR,TH T IERAL AIDFF
PEEHIMEESHABOT VET R.UABO OANPA
OR TT.TIPE TINAKECO THES.EG BEEL
US EEEDPUSINTH AF  UOADOCU,EDEID
S  FAYVEIN'SECERO
F ST A UNDEA OOUBRSGHEWE  Y FOLM
NGRITUTTH ,US METHLSUTF DETURNAB
AKOVI INDIUMLY C I WUC IRE UR TD
.LLATEMNTUSENIGSI LE P S T STTEI
R I TTO C T UNTED>>RYG ED SEBEA
OU FOUDIORIT CA O E SINT
E O ITHEL
ELITEEYH
EYG.
AOT D. OIS
EL Y SE
DI
IAPLP.HASSEKFCONIERSOKNDLEREIOE
EVEYON A H.OCELE,ATENINA CTEOTA>
ME PENHOCO
TDUTTEELALSTOR
DNICTH. T
I HA
IOFN
AEY FAR T C
TDVEFF IIEOUEETRNGNSOM HSMUE T
ULNG
E, O ON A M E'TWETTE
RALI E ECETE
TIOPLTEAYED  TIGD  AFOSIILLOT.N
HE
SOLN UKLL UBIORY A PHEWOOUHI W
SEIS WEN
SSNOVE HNUMACCR OATAS I
HE WD  AD F UT REOMFO.ORTSGEVELL
AON.ES HEEN
RE   IY
FD MP
OWPRTHEST',SI W ITH SUNIND.IN T
E
REDSACRA
NONI IZA EILLROYRKLDWA
S HACUERHASETA
A WTS AVPTIEWRS.
T A
T
REE'IF AHA>>MITH O TEN
ARNE I